non jamais aucun je crois qu'ils en ont
besoin comme plusieurs elle [ __ ] pour
perdre du poids et en plus de
l'entraînement
nathalie la forêt un régime alimentaire
très particulier j'ai pas mangé je
m'entends s'entraîner après une journée
complète sans manger
c'est maintenant une habitude pour elle
qui pratique depuis un an
le jeûne intermittent chaque matin elle
ne consomme qu'un café elle y ajoute
simplement un morceau de beurre et de la
crème jamais d'aliments solides pour le
petit déjeuner et deux fois par semaine
le jeune se prolonge jusqu'au souper un
mode d'alimentation qu'elle a adoptée à
l'automne 2017
nathalie pèse alors plus de 250 libre ça
médecin lui sert une sévère mise en
garde me dis carrément alors quand
essayé toutes les aides parce que
j'imagine que tout essayé la détresse la
chirurgie bariatrique - là ça m'a donné
un choc
pas question de chirurgie pour nathalie
qui décident de débuter avec sa
conjointe
ce régime drastique j'ai décidé de
demander d'arrêter de manger deux frères
un jaune
les premiers jeunes intermittents
étaient vraiment difficiles
la première fois qu'on l'a fait en 24
heures on voulait mourir les l'habitude
s'installe la perte de poids aussi
depuis le mois de janvier il être 87
livre moi j'ai perdu 65 livres et les
autres éducateurs comme son taux de
cholestérol et sa pression artérielle
s'améliore je suis vraiment confiant que
le cas mes prochains résultats laquelle
je vais aller voir bientôt ils vont être
comme parfait s'est fait débarquer clash
capote
une semaine plus tard chez sa maîtresse
des résultats semblent conclure mais
tente en début de parcours dans le fond
tu étais à 253 points 5
le bilan sanguin de nathalie s'est aussi
améliorée la docteure bourdu à roye qui
prône une dit
faible en glucides et le jeune
intermittents affirme voir ces
changements chez plusieurs de ses
patients une amélioration graduelle et
progressive du trafic dans le sens de
l'insulinémie on voit souvent le
cholestérol s'améliorer on voit la
pression baisser le docteur martin
juneau de l'institut de cardiologie de
montréal propose aussi le jeune des
patients qui ont des problèmes
chroniques d'embonpoint
vous avez un effet qui est très
significatif pour l'hypertension
artérielle
excellent pour le diabète de type 2 pour
des gens qui ont des problèmes des
lipides cholestérol élevé etc
mais les nutritionnistes sont moins
affirmatifs on a trop peu de données
pour se prononcer sur les avantages sur
le contrôle de la glycémie de sucre dans
le sang par exemple ou du cholestérol
ils remettent en cause les avantages du
jeune comme méthode de contrôle du poids
la question c'est est ce qu'on peut
avoir ce mode de vie nos à long terme et
la réponse est probablement non
[Musique]
nathalie elle veut poursuivre ces jeunes
intermittents elle fête son 50e
anniversaire en février et de s'offrir
un cadeau une participation au grand
défi pierre lavoie anges rue proche
parent de loin je pars de loin mais je
vais y arriver
elle a fait un très très grand bout de
chemin des jeux
ici david gêne-t-il et radio canada
montréal
non